sa il demone tutti gli altri linguaggi
possibili immaginabili
tranne l'italiano perché l'italiano fa
schifo e non lo mettono mancano i giochi
stupidi bene così non si tratta di
spider man
insomma tutti quei giochi figli si
tratta di script del punto io come che
non c'è l'italiano mi hanno raggiunto 17
linguaggi tra cui il macedone e non mi
mettono italiana
intanto christian orlando ci abbiamo
comunque noi vorrei capire allora c'era
il personaggio personalizzabile e io da
schifosa la persona che sono non l'avevo
fatto quindi ok play vi riassumo il
gioco per chi non lo conoscesse dobbiamo
cercare di dominare che cosa disegnano
gli altri e che cosa disegno anche io
perchè in teoria disegnerò anche io
allora questo è un uomo man stort stort
man palestrato man
noi ci sono tante gare in inglese quello
ha indovinato che ha perso la stupida
six pack cosa non andava bene di questa
scritta promesso la s maiuscola li
mortacci mia e di team ha inventato era
si spegne hai fatto il pisellino
piccolissimo però va bene devo
ricordarmi di scrivere la parola tutta
minuscolo tutto in maiuscolo
ripartiamo dal round 1 questa la
tutorial gamer girls choosing nimega 09
è nata nel 2009 la tel 2009 vuol dire
che ha 9 anni
qui in azione 2009 19 anni sto morendo
lentamente non me ne rendo conto
albero veramente brutto ti prego lo so
che non hai fatto l'artistico lo so che
ti sta impegnando lo so che è in nove
anni ma cristo io a tre anni disegnavo
meglio cos'è una spina nel cose
complimenti
ottimo disegno
reali nails ai si cerchi like picasso
sera cos'era spiegami cos'è un cuoca una
skitters cos'è una sfida ward devo
disegnare io ma non so che o mio dio va
bene ci provo allora è difficilissimo 1
rai dominato finissimo ok visto
veramente impegnando giuro due rami
dominato loro dai sono fiero di me
stesso e ho sbagliato e vabbè avete
vinto comunque la maggior parte hanno
dominato non sono fatto grave thank you
thank you know out or just one giu
allora tondo rotondo è una faccia che
non riesco a cape che non si capisce una
sega di quello che disegna la gente
cos'è bowling bowling pole man ball in
mente come ha fatto è la terra non è la
terra orbita orbita intorno a saturno e
la terra questa perché mi è rimasto il
secchio è una cosa come fa questo
indovinare tutte le parole spiegami che
tre chiusi bubblegum quello era un tipo
che masticavano gli hai fatto neanche la
bocca non c'era a gesù avesse la gente e
son rituali grichting si situa madre la
parola era sedia ero lì lì è questo che
indovina le parole prima che le
inventino bollo inizio per scrivere
parole a caso certi giraffe dollar tmo
nei big dollar big money fa vj free j
honey graber
quello indovina sempre cribbio com'è
possibile bitcoin si vabbè ma polizia
lasagna join the game almeno no almeno
aveva una gioia le stato subito teac
creature io are the hurting cento per
cento
intanto indovina quell'altro sono
convinto quello che vuoi cos'è ma cocco
scure gita scolastica roller coaster era
coaster senza roller
mammamia meno male che questo sì
incriccato indovinava lui o mi sta
insultando perchè gli ho detto che città
o se blasé pagatissimo non so ma sei
sicuro che il roller cost che costa che
significa significhi per montagne russe
roller coaster montagne russe costa sarà
solo russe consta vuol dire biscotto
dire sottopentola what a io la parola
xilofono magazine
allora magazine facciamo così cimino
impegnati e poi c'è l'omino di playboy
che si tiene una mano sul pacco è anche
con piselli yes man
cos'è questo è un magazine o non è
difficile è veramente easy e lei borma
che comics il copy il fumetto di playboy
va bene tu leggi il fumetto di playboy e
non è difficile
albano sai con le notizie di albano e
romina dove le mettono sul magazine
regalo mica ve l'ho detto c'era barak
obama joyner questo che cos'è
cribbio la donna difficilissimo
complimenti boc
il book di playboy complimenti brava
nicole a gesù santo sta recuperando però
sono arrivato secondo sopra tonizzo cosa
che se anche da juve new ventures
bianconero che l'inchiesta fa spiega
mezzi ti prego un acquario acquari a
cuba
hai un dio c'è così si gioca vi so se
sei veramente tu risolse sto giocando
contro uno youtuber da un sacco di
iscritti vediamo iscritti a piece of
facci lunga del b source può giocare
contro 13 milioni di iscritti vabbè
tanto primo io cioè secondo dai
facilissimo acqui acqui lium questo come
ha fatto essere primo spiega niguarda
sono 100 punti indietro a meno di 100
punti indietro solo posso recuperare
incredibile una certa e diventa non sa
più scrivere meno male perché dono noche
no c'è ball volleyball basket cavolo dai
bug basket basket ball
cos'è sta roba spiega mi dissocio
indovinato li mortacci mia no cribbio
quello lì ha preso pizza quella non è
una pizza caso con le non erano tutti
napoletani vadano cercate lo vi prego
non sta insultando tutti vi prego no
questo e mi è passato davanti per una
pizza che sembrava un calzino di mia
nonna orribile so ancora quanti in 195
con la presi 300 schifoso l'aido il si è
comprato tutto il gioco dai maledizione
ce la posso fare
l'impegno c'è
no ball 22 moon veramente sto sparando
parola caso red colour line hot dog dog
cribbio non lo so glock primo indovinato
il secondo prima di te fai schifo blog
lo vuol dire risplendere questo e
dovrebbe essere il sole questo il sole
dopo che tua sorella ci si è seduta
sopra però però vabbè dio 270 punti
guarda se quello dove a indovinare per
secondo limite o nikolle portami la
vittoria
devo arrivare primo e lui deve arrivare
almeno terzo ti supplico siamo alle giri
finali o minchiate è possibile come come
ha fatto disegnato due cerchi come
formava andate a cagare tutti i morite
sia thing del pil tua sorella che sto
affatto 22 cerchi così io non esco a
dominarla così si guardino donna
guardate guardate veramente guarda dal
non mi far parlare per cortesia perché
guardo incommentabile schifoso cittone
come hai fatto come fai essere balder
vuol dire che l'ato non capelli anche di
sos e pelato anche risorse pelato dove
sei pelato come fai tu non indovinare
per athos e un pelato non indovina chi è
pelato vuol dire che questo sta citando
non è possibile
com'è possibile mi fa incazzare che
questi che su questa è una cagata perché
non è indovini questa che hanno pagato a
questa veramente la sun che mia cugina
nata ieri come fa indovinare questo
spiega melo
spiegamelo cosa tienila la matita lì ti
prendi per il culo solo come fai a non
indovinare scapperà cagata cioè
indovinato pelato prima da
dai gli ha dato comunque il secondo
punto nonostante non abbia scritto
niente with art
signori giù tar meno vale la miss
spelling e gli ha fatto perdere un sacco
di buio grazie grazie mille nei punti
siete molto gentili dio è secondo il
primo uno che città più di sua sorella e
terzo vizio complimenti ragazzi mi siete
piaciuti tantissimo
meno male che con l'arrestato se non le
stavo io vai tyler blevins d'esposito e
join the game o rossi che ci divertiamo
non le star e per favore cosa diavolo è
tostapane toaster cribbio asimmetria
dove prima dallas che bella sfida tra
l'altro va bene e la madonna un lupo
wolf yen o e una fox guarda semi chi ha
fatto benissimo che calcio è un fenomeno
è bravissimo a disegnare come problema
che la parola non è lupo però wow una
iena tieni a porsche esalta wolf è un
cavallo sesta robben canne coyote ci
aveva azzeccato quasi azzeccato
vabbè vabbè ragazzi la vittoria non c'è
ma c'è nel cuore
l'importante è quello il pro capite sia
preceduto ragazzi sono faccio schifo a
giocare però mi sono impegnato dai parà
qualcosa spero vi sia piaciuto ragazzi
come al solito sfide che cercano è un mi
piace anche al instagram che come ogni
video toto la descrizione questi
discrete vi e noi ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo video ragazzi
[Musica]
no